[Music]
former U.S president Donald Trump has
pleaded not guilty to 37 charges related
to the handling of government secrets
appearing in a federal court Trump faced
accusations including willful retention
of National Defense information and
conspiracy to obstruct Justice Trump who
is campaigning for the 2024 presidential
election says the indictment marks one
of the saddest days in the history of
the country Alan Fisher begins our
coverage from Miami
we have a rich country we have a country
that's corrupt we have a country that's
got no borders we have a country that's
got nothing but problems We're a nation
in Decline and then they do this to find
Donald Trump greeted in Miami just
minutes after being freed temporarily
from the custody of the government he
once LED he stopped off at a Cuban
American Cafe a hotbed of supporters
[Applause]
his historic court appearance lasted 47
minutes there were no cameras in court
to record the moment Donald Trump faces
37 charges prosecutors say he skimmed
and lied to stop the government
recovering sensitive documents dealing
with America's nuclear Arsenal and
Military Readiness his lawyer entered a
plea of not guilty before the hearing
one of his legal team attacked the
prosecution what we are witnessing today
is the blatant and Unapologetic
weaponization of the Criminal Justice
System
the Biden appointed special counsel has
sought fit to bring 37 federal charges
against President Trump the leading
front-runner less than a year and a half
before an election the police were ready
for a crowd of up to 50 000 it was
nowhere near as big the majority showing
their support for the former president a
few voices of dissent the American
people are not stupid anymore they
realize what it is and his poll numbers
are going to go up he's not going to
pull out of the race no matter what and
he's going to win with an overwhelming
Landslide the current indictment is
based on his own words and uh the
testimony of its closest advisors and
lawyers so this is the slam dunk
Trump was released on bond he didn't
have to post money or surrender his
passport but he's forbidden from talking
to Witnesses unless it's through their
lawyers
as his motorcade left the courthouse it
was rushed by a lone protester who was
quickly taken to the ground and arrested
back at his Bedminster golf estate in
New Jersey the former president felt
comfortable to go on the attack once
more pledging to fight the charges
I'm not the one who thinks I'm above the
law I'm the one that followed the law
I'm the only one
it's Joe Biden and his corrupt
Department of Injustice
just think they are above the law
never before have the two standards of
Justice in our country been more starkly
revealed Donald Trump clearly believes
he's won the battle in the court of
public opinion with his own supporters
and potential Republican voters but the
actual court case goes on with legal
arguments Discovery and the potential
that a former president of the United
States could go on trial here before the
end of the year and at the height of the
Republican primary season
Alan Fisher Al Jazeera Miami
oh Gabriel Elizondo is in Bedminster New
Jersey with more on Trump's speech
Donald Trump just wrapped up his speech
here at his golf resort and he was
certainly defiant with a capital D he
repeated some of the same themes that
we've heard from him in recent days uh
calling this an evil and heinous
indictment saying that they are fake and
fabricated charges and saying that this
day will live down in Infinity for all
the wrong reasons Trump also alluding to
those uh now famous photographs of those
boxes of documents that were in his
bathroom at Mar-A-Lago he's saying that
simply those were his personal
belongings that he took from the White
House that he simply hadn't got time to
go through yet he said they were filled
with newspaper clippings
photographs and things of those sort
sort of making it out to be a very
innocent situation and nothing a
criminal whatsoever
but clearly the indictment paints a much
different picture than what the picture
that the former president wanted to
paint here in front of his high dollar
donors that have been gathered here uh
waiting for him for many hours they will
now go inside the gulf Resort they'll
have a private dinner and a campaign
fundraiser where he's expected to make
as much as two million dollars tonight
alone for his campaign certainly a
surreal scene here as Trump is making
his first major
comments since his court appearance in
Miami
gabrielizando Al Jazeera Bedminster New
Jersey